[Aplausos]
[Música]
a estas alturas parece que el régimen de
Vladimir Putin es indestructible la
economía está aguantando las sanciones
comerciales mucho mejor de lo que muchos
esperaban aunque como ya os hemos
contado en nuestro boletín de patreon
las cosas han comenzado a cambiar con la
llegada del 2023 pero es este tema para
otro vídeo sea como sea Putin ha sido
capaz de sofocar todas las protestas y
tampoco parece que sea inminente una
rebelión interna en el círculo más
próximo al kremlin sin embargo Y si el
problema estuviera fuera de Moscú dicho
de otra forma Hasta qué punto las
regiones de la periferia del país
podrían separarse de la madre Rusia
algún día de verdad es esto posible
puede que os sorprenda pero este es uno
de los mayores miedos del mismísimo
Putin atentos
En otras palabras que la posible
balcanización de Rusia no es algo que
nos inventemos aquí en visualpolitik es
un miedo que tiene el propio Vladimir
Putin
y lo cierto Es que hay motivos para
pensar que Rusia podría separarse algún
día pensad que hablamos de un país
enorme con un montón de etnias y
nacionalidades que poco tienen que ver
con los rusos de Moscú y no aquí no solo
estamos hablando de los territorios Como
chechenia por ejemplo sabíais que la
República de tartastán que es esta
región que veis aquí en el mapa estuvo a
punto de convertirse en un estado
independiente y soberano y no hace falta
remontarse muy atrás en el tiempo
hablamos del año 1992 y este es solo un
ejemplo administrativamente Rusia se
compone de 84 entes territoriales
diferentes y Eso sin contar con lo que
se han anexionado de Ucrania y las
diferencias entre unos territorios y
otros son abismales
[Música]
por ejemplo en el plano económico Rusia
es terriblemente desigual mucho más
incluso que la Unión Europea y todas sus
constantes ampliaciones por ejemplo el
pib Per cápita de la región más rica del
país puede ser según el precio del
petróleo hasta 60 veces más alto que el
del territorio más pobre y la Guerra de
Ucrania está sirviendo para aumentar
estas diferencias aún más y ya sé lo que
estaréis pensando muchos buenas noticias
para occidente verdad pues no tan rápido
una ruptura interna en Rusia podría
desencadenar una crisis internacional de
proporciones Nacho vidalianas pensadlo
así quién se quedaría con el Arsenal
nuclear ruso como podéis ver hablamos de
un escenario que sea más o menos
probable necesita que estemos preparados
y por eso en el vídeo de hoy vamos a
centrarnos en uno de los aspectos
centrales de la política rusa y a la vez
uno de los más desconocidos fuera del
país Así que la pregunta que hoy nos
hacemos Es de verdad Rusia puede llegar
a desintegrarse territorialmente pueden
perder territorios que territorios
serían estos Y por qué querrían
separarse hoy vamos a responder a estas
preguntas pero antes vamos a ver un poco
de historia
[Música]
las fronteras cambiantes de Rusia
si estudiáis la historia de Rusia veréis
que hay tres leyes de hierro que se han
cumplido durante siglos la primera es
que Rusia siempre tiende a expandirse sí
es cierto que otros muchos países
También tienen disputas territoriales
pero el caso de Rusia es especial por
ejemplo esto que veis aquí es la
República de tuba con un territorio
equivalente a tres Costa ricas
durante casi toda su historia esta zona
ha estado controlada por china sin
embargo desde 1944 es territorio ruso
ojo no es que fuera territorio de la
unión soviética no hablamos de Rusia
Pero esperad porque aún hay más esto
otro que veis es la isla de sajalin que
es tan grande como todo Austria durante
siglos estuvo dominada por china Japón y
Rusia desde 1905 los rusos se la dieron
a Los japoneses pero tras la Segunda
Guerra Mundial volvieron a recuperarla
en su totalidad y podríamos seguir con
otros tantos territorios primos
pero la expansión de Rusia no terminó en
la Segunda Guerra Mundial en 2014 Rusia
se anexo no crimea y el año pasado en
202 se anexionaron al menos sobre el
papel la República del Tomás y sí
estamos hablando de anexiones es decir
en los mapamundis rusos tanto crimea
como el don vas son territorios tan
rusos como el mismísimo San Petersburgo
dicho de otra forma Rusia continúa
moviendo sus fronteras Incluso hoy en
día independientemente de los acuerdos
internacionales que haya firmado
la segunda constante en historia rusa es
la incapacidad del kremlin para enviar
recursos y servicios públicos a todos
los confines de su territorio da igual
que hablemos de la Rusia de los zares la
Rusia soviética o la Rusia de Putin
Moscú siempre intenta controlar todo el
país desde el kremlin con resultados
desastrosos esto provoca un montón de
tensiones regionales y tensiones étnicas
y esto nos lleva a la tercera constante
en la historia de Rusia la tensión entre
centralismo y federalismo es decir
dependiendo del momento histórico
Moscú ha intentado dar más autonomía a
sus regiones y luego se la ha quitado y
ahora la pregunta es si Rusia puede
ganar territorios también puede
perderlos pues ahora mismo lo vamos a
ver
las independientes dentro de Rusia
[Música]
si os interesa la política rusa hay algo
que os va a llamar la atención tanto
chechenia como Dark Stand como sajas Son
regiones de Rusia pero se autodenominan
como repúblicas independientes y diréis
esto Qué significa son independientes o
son parte de Rusia como puede ser
independiente y a la vez parte de un
país Pues bien aquí es donde entra en
escena este señor que veis en pantalla
Exacto hablamos de yoshiff staling sí
del mismo stalin de los gulags y las
deportaciones cuando los comunistas
llegaron al poder se dieron cuenta de
que hay dos rugias muy distintas la
parte central y la periferia que tiene
etnias muy distintas durante siglos los
zares habían expandido su territorio en
ocasiones al ritmo de una nueva Bélgica
al año como resultado había montones de
regiones cuya relación con Moscú era
simplemente el tributo que tenían que
pagar y los jóvenes que tenían que
mandar en Las Guerras por lo demás
tenían una cultura religión o incluso un
idioma distinto y no penséis que
hablamos de territorios pequeños
por ejemplo esto que veis aquí es la
República de Sahara tiene el tamaño de
seis países como España lo que la
convierte en la región más grande de
toda Rusia y está poblada por los
yacudos que ni siquiera hablan una
lengua eslava y esto que veis aquí es la
República de buriatti es tan grande como
Alemania y también tiene su propio
idioma emparentado en este caso con el
mongol Pues bien stalin entendía que la
mejor forma de encargar todos estos
territorios en su nuevo utopía comunista
era darles un estatus especial permitir
que estas regiones mantuvieran su propio
idioma su propia cultura y sus propias
tradiciones por supuesto la religión era
un tema parte porque para eso eran
comunistas pero eso es otra historia y
así es como nacieron la repúblicas
autónomas de Rusia es decir regiones
dentro de la propia Rusia pero que
podían tener su propia Constitución
mantener su idioma y su cultura ojo no
confundir repúblicas autónomas con
repúblicas socialistas soviéticas es
decir una cosa es Ucrania o kazajistán
que eran parte de la URSS pero no parte
de Rusia sin embargo la República de
Sahara de la que hablábamos antes por
ejemplo sí que era parte integral de
Rusia es decir ley de hierro número 3 el
kremlin no puede gestionar todos sus
territorios y Busca un nuevo encaje pero
este buenrollismo dura solo una década
porque básicamente en 1938 el propio
stalin volvió a imponer el ruso como
lengua obligatoria y comenzaron las
deportaciones y la marginación cultural
sin embargo la figura legal de la
república autónomas se mantuvo Y esto es
muy importante Por qué pues atentos
cuando Rusia casi se rompe
Unión soviética años 80 y 90 todo el
país está al borde del colapso
conclusión territorio rusos que se
quieren separar del yugo de Moscú para
evitar un colapso total el por entonces
líder soviético Michael gorbachov aprobó
la llamada ley de repúblicas autónomas
el 26 de abril de 1990 la URSS dio el
mismo estatus legal a la República rusas
que a la República soviéticas dicho de
otra forma que por ejemplo chechenia
podría haber roto con Rusia pero haber
seguido integrada en la unión soviética
con el mismo encaje que tendría por
ejemplo Ucrania o kazajistán el problema
con esta ley Pues que meses más tarde el
mismo gorbachov tuvo que terminar
renunciando la disolución de toda la
unión soviética Ucrania los bálticos
todos estos soviets se convirtieron en
nuevos países independientes Pero y qué
pasa dentro de Rusia Pues que muchas de
estas repúblicas autónomas se
preguntaron seguimos siendo parte de
Rusia o no Si los ucranianos en
independizado porque no los chechenos o
los tártaros conclusión que en cada una
de estas repúblicas hicieron su
referéndums para ver si querían quedar
dentro de Rusia o no y qué queréis que
pasó
Pues que hubo repúblicas que votaron por
ser independientes la historia de
chechenia ya la conocéis pero ojo porque
no fueron los únicos por ejemplo aquí
tenéis el caso de tatastán
los tártaros son una etnia muy distinta
de la rusa son musulmanes hablan el
idioma tártaro que también es una lengua
turca y tienen su propia historia y
hasta sus propios nombres y por si
algunos se lo está preguntando no no
tienen nada que ver con la salsa tártara
Pues bien en 1992 los tártaros votaron
en un referéndum no tuvo terminación 82%
de participación y 61% a favor de la
soberanía lo que la mayoría
interpretaron como independencia
y como os podéis imaginar esto hizo
saltar las alarmas del kremlin otras
Yesenia otra región más que se quiere
separar otra región más donde Tendremos
que mandar al ejército Pues por suerte
en este caso yelsin consiguió
convencerles de que se quedaran Y diréis
cómo Pues con buen rollis muy
negociación Durante los años 90 el
kremlin negoció tratados bilaterales con
todas y cada una de estas repúblicas
autónomas esto explica que cada
República haya tenido más o menos
autonomía dependiendo de cómo negociaran
con el bono de yelsin en el caso de Stan
como se querían ir a Moscú no le quedó
otro remedio que darles más autonomía
que a nadie y eso explica que durante
más de dos décadas los tártaros han
podido tener sus propios impuestos o
incluso su propia política exterior y
diréis esto en que se traduce Pues en
que la República independiente de todas
están tiene mejores infraestructuras y
está mucho más industrializada que las
regiones vecinas En otras palabras que
parecía que yelsin había encontrado la
solución para integrar a todas las
etnias rusas en la federación vale Sí
hablamos de un federalismo un tanto
desigual pero funcionaba el problema
recordad la tercera ley de hierro rusa
busca mos un nuevo encaje a todos los
territorios pero el buenrollismo dura lo
que tarda en llegar un nuevo inquilino
al kremlin atentos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
Putin y la vuelta al centralismo
[Música]
os hago una pregunta cómo se llama el
partido político de Vladimir Putin
Exacto Rusia unida Y créeme el nombre no
es casualidad Putin es el federalismo
buenrollista
en 2004 Putin eliminó la elección
democrática de gobernadores regionales
cierto en 2013 volvió a restaurarla pero
con muchísimas comillas dicho de otra
forma los líderes regionales están
elegidos de un modo u otro por Moscú
para que os hagáis una idea entre los
años 2012 y 2018 el kremlin reemplazó a
63 gobernadores
[Música]
Y sí Eso incluye a la muy independiente
y muy soberana desde 2017 han perdido
hasta su capacidad de tener sus propios
impuestos en otras palabras que a día de
hoy ya podemos decir que Rusia vuelve a
ser una República Federal solo en nombre
Todas las decisiones se toman desde
Moscú Y eso se nota sobre todo en el
dinero para que os hagáis una idea entre
2012 y 2018 los ingresos Fiscales Del
kremlin medidos en rubros que no en
dólares crecieron un 77% mientras que
los de las regiones solo un 3% y diréis
Qué significa todo esto regla número 3
te damos independencia para que te
quedes y a los pocos años te la quitamos
y ya sé lo que pensaréis muchos tiene
lógica un país con tantísimas
desigualdades territoriales necesita
redistribución de recursos por ejemplo
el 80% de los recursos de chechania
viene del kremlin pero este centralismo
tiene unos problemas económicos muy
grandes y la Guerra de Ucrania no ayuda
por qué pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
y en mucho abarca poco aprieta
a día de hoy año 2023 se calcula que el
20% de la población rusa no tiene acceso
a agua corriente Por ejemplo en muchas
zonas de la República de saja donde
pueden llegar a los 40 grados bajo cero
en invierno tiene que comprar bloques de
hielo todos los días para calentarlos y
así tener agua limpia y esto explica por
qué media Rusia está vacía para que os
hagáis una idea el distrito de extremo
Oriente supone el 41% del territorio
Ruso y solo el 5,5% de la población Por
supuesto que el clima no juega a favor
de Rusia pero no solo es una cuestión de
clima sino también de gestión de
recursos y aquí voy a hacer un
paréntesis el problema de Rusia con el
extremo Oriente da para un vídeo en sí
mismo y tiene mucho que ver con la
estrategia de Putin de pivotar hacia
Asia pero se trata de un tema en el que
merece la pena detenerse y fijarse mucho
en los detalles vamos que es café para
los muy cafeteros y por eso en lugar de
publicarlo en abierto lo vamos a
reservar para los que no seguís en
nuestra comunidad de patreon ya sabéis
que podéis apoyar a visualpolitik
entrando en nuestro patreon desde ahí
recibiréis nuestras dos newsletters
semanales exclusivas que son las claves
de la semana y la tan politik Pero
además vamos a subir contenido exclusivo
donde tratamos temas con mayor
profundidad para todos los más
apasionados de la política internacional
Así que lo dicho en nuestro patreon
podréis ver pronto un análisis con mucha
más profundidad sobre los problemas de
Putin a la hora de desarrollar la parte
asiática de Rusia pero ahora sigamos con
el vídeo de hoy
porque Moscú tiene un problema de
proporciones Nacho vidalianas a la hora
de llevar infraestructuras a todo el
país por ejemplo algo que os va a
sorprender Rusia apenas tiene puentes
Cómo os quedáis mientras Estados Unidos
tiene alrededor de 600.000 puentes Rusia
que es 1,7 veces más grande tiene
alrededor de 42.000 puentes y esto se
traduce en zonas del tamaño de toda
Europa occidental donde es casi
imposible encontrar trabajos y diréis
Pero por qué no pueden construir
infraestructuras pues vamos a ver un
ejemplo el puente de jacuzz que estaría
en la capital de la República de Sahara
este proyecto se frenó en Seco en el año
2014 Y diréis por qué Pues porque es
justo ese año cuando Rusia invadió la
Península de crimea de repente la
prioridad del kremlin pasó a ser el
desarrollo de su nuevo territorio crimea
casi todo el dinero se fue para
proyectos como el del puente de kers que
conecta crimea con el resto de Rusia eso
y proyectos faraónicos como los Juegos
Olímpicos de invierno de Sochi que
fueron uno de los más caros de la
historia solo en este proyecto el
kremlin se dejó más de 16.000 millones
de dólares casi el doble de los 9 mil
millones de dólares que pensaban
invertir para desarrollar el distrito
del lejano Oriente entendéis por dónde
voy ahora el kremlin tiene poder casi
ilimitado para gestionar todo el
presupuesto de Rusia y ahora Putin tiene
otras prioridades por encima de
desarrollar todas las regiones por un
lado necesita incrementar el gasto
militar pero por el otro necesita
mantener las cuentas controladas
conclusión muchas regiones están
quedando marginadas de hecho se calcula
que para 2024 el 68% del pib de toda
Rusia venga solo de las 12 regiones más
prósperas pero esperad un momento porque
no solo hablamos de dinero también
Hablamos de Vidas de dónde creéis que
viene la mayor parte de Las bajas de la
Guerra de Ucrania Pues fijaos en esta
aproximación que seguramente se quede
corta pero que nos dice muy bien Por
dónde van los tiros nunca mejor dicho
[Música]
en el momento en el que hacemos este
vídeo Moscú ha perdido a 98 soldados si
tenemos en cuenta que Moscú tiene 13
millones de habitantes podemos decir que
la mayoría de las familias muskovitas
duermen tranquilas ahora bien qué pasa
en otras regiones como la República de
buriattia en este caso hablamos de 452
caídos es decir que por lo menos uno de
cada 2000 habitantes han muerto en la
guerra en otros sitios como la República
de tuba encontramos cifras muy parecidas
dicho de otra forma que cada vez hay más
gente en estas regiones de la periferia
que conoce personalmente a caídos en la
guerra una guerra que se está
produciendo a miles de kilómetros de
distancia pensad que la distancia que
hay entre la República de tuba y Ucrania
es la misma que hay entre España y
Armenia y todo esto explica que están
empezando a surgir montones de
movimientos de autodeterminación de
hecho en 2022 nació el Foro de las
Naciones libres de Rusia donde se están
empezando a organizar varios de estos
movimientos separatistas como de grandes
esta organización no lo sabemos De
verdad vamos a ver un movimiento
separatista en Rusia es muy pronto para
decirlo y de darse algo así podría ser
muchos muchos años como decimos siempre
en visualpolitik no podemos predecir el
futuro pero sí podemos decir que los
problemas de la Rusia zarista persisten
en la Rusia de Putin y De igual forma
que Rusia ha tenido ya tensiones étnicas
en el pasado podría volver a tenerlas en
un futuro no tan lejano en cualquier
caso Hay un montón de temas que hemos
tenido que dejar en el tintero Y si
queréis más sobre este tipo de
cuestiones os esperamos en nuestro
patreon Mientras tanto ahora la pregunta
es para vosotros veremos una nueva
oleada de movimientos separatistas será
capaz de Rusia de encontrar otro nuevo
encaje a todas estas repúblicas y en
caso de que no fuera así qué pasaría con
todo el Arsenal nuclear ruso En manos de
quién quedaría podéis dejarme vuestra
respuesta en los comentarios y como
siempre no olvidéis Que aquí en
visualpolitik sacamos vídeos nuevos
Todas las semanas así que suscribíos a
este canal y dadle a la campanita para
no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si os ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un saludo y hasta pronto
[Música]